police departments nationwide are
working to bridge the gaps between
officers and the communities they serve
african-americans make up 47 percent of
the population in Washington DC a recent
survey found 83 percent of the people
subjected to stop and frisk in the
capital or black the police in the
city's mayor are addressing racial bias
with help from the National Museum of
african-american history and culture
jeff Pigasus is outside the museum with
the mission of this unique training Jeff
good morning good morning law
enforcement officials across the country
now acknowledge the link between black
history in America and the current
divide between police and community and
that is why DC police now mandate this
new training which includes a tour of
this museum which compels officers to
explore black history in such a way that
it reduces tension on the streets
between police and community what I want
to do is introduce why Washington DC is
known as the black mecca of America
Bernard M Chuck is led hundreds of
police officers on tours through
historically black neighborhoods in the
center of DC known as Shaw and u Street
murals tell a story we don't want to
hide our history behind closed doors and
Chuck says those neighborhoods have a
history of oppression at the hands of a
police force that was majority white
believers were mostly young Negro men
and women racial tensions caused riots
in this neighborhood when dr. Martin
Luther King jr. was assassinated the
first brick went through the window of a
store that would not hire African
Americans fires set by the rioters
burned blocks of buildings to the ground
fifty years later resentment still
simmers for tension be conscious of it
over the last year Metropolitan Police
have seen a 36 percent rise in use of
force incidents in 2016 DC police were
involved in the deadly shooting of
Terrence sterling an unarmed black man
which led to protests
in another high-profile case an officer
was photographed wearing a shirt with
racist imagery officers were Jenna Grier
Melvin Evans and Sarah snap Co say
police often feel the tension when they
walk the beat I was called names and it
was very uncomfortable it was different
and I couldn't understand why there was
that conflict and this is one of the
reasons why this training is such a
benefit officer snap Co worked in the
Shaw neighborhood just knowing the
history the background I hope that
reverberates with the community that
they realized we want we want to know
all three our trainers at the police
academy and have taken the tour learning
this type of information and then going
out onto the beat do you think officer
Greer that that lowers the temperature
level it makes everyone feel a little
bit more at ease I really believe that
it does when you look at past history
you don't want to repeat the same
mistakes again when you look at mistakes
in law enforcement you see no we don't
want to go there as a department the
chief can't do his job
effectively if the community doesn't
trust him and his officers DC Mayor
Muriel Bowser joined police chief Peter
Newsom to implement the new training
hopefully you will get out of this
training what I got out of going through
this museum and it's an experience like
no other experience chief Duchamp saw
the National Museum of african-american
history and culture is a learning
opportunity we're not teaching our kids
across the country about what happened
to African Americans in this country and
I think a lot of us are missing
something there lessons he hopes they
have learned now I think more
importantly it's for our police officers
to understand how some folks in our
community feel about how the police
played a role in some of the in justices
that we have in our society officer
Evans says the training will make a
difference the only way you make a reach
or build that bridge of getting along is
it allowed people to know that I know
about you I have something that I can
talk to you about about you I understand
what you went through I understand your
concerns you learn from your community
and the community learns for you
and at the end of the day they really
know that you're here to aid in the
system this program is unique in that it
is mandatory for an entire Police
Department other cities like Chicago and
Philadelphia have started similar
courses in order to bridge the divide
between police and community Nora
what a good story Jeff thank you I can
remember talking to the former attorney
general Loretta Lynch about about cops
and neighborhoods and developing this
kind of relationship before becomes a
problem like before you get a ticket you
already have a relationships because
cops have been in the schools they're
part of the community they're your
friends they're community members before
there's a negative interaction like a
like a law enforcement yeah I
interviewed the new chief of patrol the
NYPD and Tracy Kersey she's the chief
for training they're taking this stuff
very seriously as well you got to invest
the time though Indiana